Nice work, now I think ordering
methods can actually be used
to solve another issue.
Here take a look.
When I start shopping mode and
I buy something, it crosses it off,
which is great.
But what would be even more great
is if when I cross an item off,
it could actually be in
a different part of the list.
So maybe down here I would have all
the items that I've already bought and
separated up here it would be the items
that haven't been bought yet.
I have a feeling that
using a sorting query
you could separate out the bought
items from the un-bought items.
I'll go ahead and send over the spec
which outlines exactly what I want, and
maybe you can take a stab at it.